assassins creed valhalla and assassin's
creed
odyssey two games in the same franchise
but
two very different ones does assassin's
creed valhalla build upon the
quote-unquote new assassin's creed
experience
that was honed by odyssey or is it
something completely different
altogether well joining me
to help answer that question we've got
jordan remain hey
assassin's creed just nerd over here
who's played pretty much
all the game several times and reviewed
valhalla i call myself an assassin's
creed fan but i defer to you
in every regard i don't think there's
anyone better on staff
who uh who can add to this debate it's
not even really a debate it's just a
kind of
a look at the key differences between
the two games so let's
get started
[Music]
let's start by talking about gameplay so
when i said the quote unquote new
assassin's creed experience
i am of course referring to the fact
that the origins
pun not intended of this franchise were
very much rooted in
action adventure social stealth parkour
and then with assassin's creed origins
it kind of had this pivot and the
franchise became
this big rpg and you know
all these elements were inserted in
origins and then like i said earlier
honed
in odyssey jordan how does valhalla
tackle the r
the rpg of assassin's creed it's
strange because on one hand valhalla
leans a little bit
more into the whole rpg style by like
just giving you this
huge ginormous skill tree to just
invest i am scared of that thing it's
it's
it's probably too big but it's it's
it's huge and then they at the same time
they kind of bring the game a little bit
back to the
roots of the franchise by bringing back
social stealth like there's
actually moments in the game where it's
like oh you have to put on the hood you
have to blend into crowds you have to
use the hidden blade which hasn't been
seen in a while like it wasn't in
odyssey so it's simultaneously a little
bit more
rpg and at the same time like taking a
small
step back to the roots of the series
no i was gonna say it feels more rained
in
i think when you think about the rpg
elements to the game i think one in one
place where that is very key is in
loot odyssey just had so
so much like it just gets to the point
where like 20 hours into that game
you're just finding like
four new bows in like an outpost and
you're just
marking them all as trash to just sell
whereas valhalla it's like
after it's 60 to 70 hour campaign i'm
like oh i have
i don't know five axes three
hammers like four shields like not a
huge amount of loot it's more kind of
based on like
finding whatever you really like and
then going back to the blacksmith to
just keep
upgrading it over and over and over
again
one of the things i was going to talk to
you about is when we said like things
are honed in a little bit is the
quest structure being a huge open world
rpg
there are many many side quests how do
you think the balance is compared to the
side quests and side activities and
world events on offer in odyssey
compared to how they are in valhalla
valhalla
in my opinion does this way better
odyssey kind of just like throws quests
at you like just
in abundance to the point where like
eventually your quest tracker is just
filled with like 20
things that you're trying to keep track
of and valhalla is
more like look your main gist of this
story is trying to make alliances with
as many people as you possibly can
you're only gonna really track the
alliance that you're focusing on
at a time which might have two or three
different objectives but
no more than that and then all the like
random
side quest things that you run into
they're kind of something you can just
wrap up in four to five minutes and
we're not going to even really track
them for you just kind of run into them
talk to someone do something go back and
that's
it and it leaves the quest like tracker
much much easier to navigate
i always consider the the kind of
unnamed
main character of assassin's creed
beyond the assassin which you play as
is definitely the world uh the time
period in which
you are playing around in you know
history is your playground after all
and two very different flavors in
valhalla and odyssey
i must say i think this kind of almost
goes
back to uh the last time we had one of
these videos when you and mike were
talking about odyssey and origins and
you were talking about how origins
really
leans into its setting and tells a story
that could really
only be told in its setting and odyssey
not really as much like it's a really
good story the story
about this uh mercenary trying to
reconnect with our family
but it's not something really that's
defined by the war going on
between the two powerhouses in greece at
that time
i feel like valhalla does a much better
job of leaning
into the fact that like this is an
england where
vikings are just coming in from like
norway in mass and they're invading
the country and there's this this mix of
cultures of christianity
and the pagan faiths and so you find all
these towns that are a mixture of
cultures and
mixtures of people and and that's like
really
cool and it leans into the story that
there's all these rulers all this
political
turmoil and avor has to kind of just
navigate
this little like political [ __ ] show for
lack of a better word to
find some place to safely have their
ravenclaws like look we just want this
one
tiny spot of land can y'all just give it
to us and everyone's
can you just kill it feels like way more
defined in terms of a world in terms of
a setting
than in odyssey where like i played as
cassandra
and you know it's she's not a fish out
of water
she's very familiar it's too hot and too
long a walk to go on foot
but think of it as interest marcus
everybody benefits she gets obviously
embroiled in some
higher level stuff let's put it that way
but you know it's
you know there's no none of this like
unfamiliarity there and the world
and i i don't want to say sami but you
know in odyssey it's just like many many
small greek islands
whereas in norway you know there's snow
there's different gameplay mechanics to
being in norway
it's you know you can't go swimming
without freezing for example
and like trudging through the snow and
then you get to england
for me as an english person is like you
kind of wander up on npcs and they go oh
what's all this then
oh my apple car have fallen these apples
must be eaten they're too juicy to be
left to rot
i would say i think like a good
comparison is the fact that like in
odyssey you have the athens and sparta
like going up against each other but you
see very
little of those two forces like really
interacting with each other and
cassandra can just kind of hop back and
forth between them with very little in
the way of alliance
whereas there are scenes like in
valhalla where
avor or like one of her companions are
talking to someone
who's like a saxon or a christian or
something like that and they're just
talking about how their two languages
are so very different but at the same
time
very much the same and it's like i've
missed this aspect of assassin's creed
the
showing how cultures just over time just
layer
on each other and that's really all
history is it's just
a bunch of cultures just colliding with
each other over and over and over again
so we've mentioned aval we've mentioned
cassandra
alexios there's obviously very different
ways that the
the two games valhalla and odyssey kind
of approach
which assassin you're gonna play as i
say both of them
have started a i don't know if it's a
precedence yet like it's happened
twice now so we'll see if it keeps
happening of you getting the choice of
playing as either a male
or a female protagonist throughout the
campaign odyssey was like you're just
locked into either cassandra or alexios
and there's a story reason
behind that so it kind of makes sense in
terms of in terms of
the actual characters themselves you
know alexios gets a lot of flack
i i never put i never played as him
because i liked cassandra i like the
strong
worst option lucy he's the worst of the
two options
i i liked cassandra because i think she
was so
she's such a strong character and i
think avor is definitely
we talked about ava being like this fish
out of water but i love
i love her she's great
i really like aboard too and i wonder if
they benefit from the fact that since
it's the same
character and you're just kind of
switching back like a commander shepard
yeah essentially it's like oh we're just
kind of focused on making just
a character that unfortunately can't
really have
any storylines that really impact their
gender in any way but we can just really
focus on writing them as a really good
character because they're the same
person avoir
i know you now sulky the snake and these
are things from my old home
how much silver did chadvi pay you to
betray us so i love the way that evil
despite being in a new country
has this link to their past that the
brother sigurd is there too
as well as other people who have come
over from norway to build your
settlement and in terms of like the
world itself
yes i love going out and doing the big
quests and forming these alliances
but i also love having a settlement this
home base
this normandy-esque if we're gonna
continue to use the mass effect
comparison i love having this like home
base to come back to
to upgrade to have recognizable faces
and characters around that i can talk to
and like romance i was saying
the fact that you it's still kind of
shallow
some of the romances that you can do
it's not like
witcher 3 or mass effect or dragon age
level
of romantic options but i do like that
there's a little bit more effort
implemented into them this time i will
say for the characters i think the one
thing that odyssey might have
over valhalla is the fact that since
odyssey is just this really really long
40 to 50 hour campaign as opposed to
60 to 70 hours of multiple
two to three hour story lines is that
you meet characters as
cassandra that you then continuously
keep meeting over and over and over
again over that time
you get to see them evolve and grow and
transform into different ways
in valhalla it's mostly you interact
with people for like
three to four hours and they're kind of
just gone
from the campaign after that some of
them do come back in other
arcs but there are just like a few
characters i'm like oh i really like
them i
hope i get to meet them again it's like
no you just never
see it in my can goodbye
excuse me i have a slight pain
do you notice anything on my head
so those are the biggest differences
between assassin's creed odyssey and
valhalla jordan i'm going to put you on
the spot
which would you recommend
is this really hard
mostly because cassandra for me is like
the new
ezio she is the protagonist in
assassin's creed to
beat and i'm not sure that avor does
that but
just between the two games i think i
like valhalla a little bit more i like
its world building i like the way that
it uses its setting to tell a very
unique story in history that you
probably wouldn't find in other video
games so i love cassandra so much
and that she but i think i have to go
with valhalla
so i put a lot of time into odyssey and
i was completely overwhelmed by it
and i ended up dropping off at the end i
like well about 50 or so i was in i
ended up dropping off
whereas i like how self-contained a lot
of the arcs
of valhalla are like personally speaking
it's cool to see these places like
leatherchestershire
obviously like leicestershire or like
norwich i've been to norwich you know
it's it's nice to be able to have that
connection with an assassin's creed game
and i'm not just saying you know oh it's
the bad game because i'm english
but most of all i just think running in
like doing raids
as a viking and just you know chopping
everyone up with my axe and
throwing things and setting stuff on
fire and i'm really enjoying that and so
i definitely would have to say i prefer
valhalla
hear it from first from from lucy it's
like i love england i love it so much
and i love to burn it down to the ground
we street we streamed it the other day
and uh unfortunately i think i said
stomp on the nun oh stomp on it stop it
ahead stop my head
should have stopped there's uh our
thoughts on assassin's creed valhalla vs
assassins
creed odyssey jordan thank you so much
pimp your review sir because it's very
good
i would say please please read it i put
a lot of work and effort into it it's a
very long game to play in a week thank
you so
much for watching let us know what you
decide in the comments below and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you